hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number
142. this is the Q a section I remain Dr
Brett Weinstein I am sitting with Dr
Heather Hein and we are ready to address
your cues with A's of ours
yes we are
so we're going to answer two questions
that came off the Discord server this
week on account of it's been a couple
weeks since we've done a q a
uh each week they uh put their heads
together and vote on which question
they'd most like us to answer and so two
of them this week first one
Warfare
um
it's not going to go well let me just
see what time is Warfare evolves
fifth generation Warfare as found in
international military literature posits
many things but mainly that the
battlefield is that of narratives and
that an individual could become as
powerful as a nation-state in that
regard
are we in the midst of World War III
already
well
there are a couple things to say here
one you have
whose famous question was it about the
pope and how many divisions he had
oh I don't know this is it Stalin I
don't think I know this some important
leader was
told by an advisor that he needed to
worry about
the Pope and he was like really how many
divisions does he have the idea of
military division yeah yeah how many
troops what's he gonna do he's gonna say
stuff right
um and the point as well all right
that's a fair point
on the other hand
hopes are important historically
um so clear clearly one does not need a
military in order to be important so
there's nothing new about the idea that
at the scale of human Warfare narrative
has always been important now narrative
plays multiple different roles sometimes
it rationalizes
um
behavior for example
Hitler
rationalized the Holocaust on the basis
that it was the Jews that were
responsible for Germany's defeat in
World War One
okay it's nonsense but the point is it
was narratively necessary to his purpose
with respect to the German people who
felt humiliated by their defeat in World
War One Etc so anyway narrative has
always been important are we in the
midst of something akin to World War III
you better believe it which doesn't mean
that there won't be a third essentially
global Military conflagration
right that's always a danger what would
we call it
um you know
World War C would be a better choice
than World War III probably because a
World War one and two were thematically
related and related through you know a
short period of history
there are certainly considerable numbers
of people who would argue that they're
effectively the same War yeah the
continuation of of the same War they
didn't deserve separate numbers yeah but
anyway I would say
look when when covet happened
I heard myself say this is the biggest
thing that has ever happened on planet
Earth and I was not unaware of world
wars and other such things right
um I still believe that it may in fact
be it was in some sense
much more Global than the world wars
right the world wars happened all over
the globe but they certainly didn't
happen everywhere
um
and the importance of what is happening
the fact that
we are watching
uh the West
collapsing at some level the West forget
what it is at the same time that uh you
know China is aggressively oppressing
its population ostensibly to prevent the
spread of covet there is something very
Global about the dysfunction on the
planet at the moment well there's also
even
typical
effects of war that we are enduring that
are not being attributed
uh to anything we're like but the supply
chain disruptions and the inflation uh
you know some some of which is just
being denied
um but you know the fact that the cost
of living the cost of goods has gone to
the roof and that uh and that it's
increasingly difficult to get many
things at all or it's going to take a
very long time to get them or it's just
unclear how long it will take to get
them
uh it's both you know we have a global
economy in a way that we didn't during I
think the world wars but those things
are perfectly consistent with wartime
economy as well so it strikes me that
um the Ancients by which I mean
people in the
50s 60s 70s 80s really well
um we're well aware that war was both
applicable and not applicable the idea
of the Cold War right you've got hot
Wars shooting Wars and Cold War
which was something of the scale of a
global conflagration but without the
bullets or at least it involved proxy
hot Wars they were still there's there's
still Weaponry obviously right and and
you know building for a war that might
come is really what the Cold War uh or
at least part of what it was about and
part of why it ended with the collapse
of the Soviet Union is effectively it
bankrupted them but
the I so I guess there is an awareness
that war is a physical phenomenon and a
metaphorical Phenomenon with many of the
same impacts and the question is what is
the right description of the kind of war
that we are
I've been clearly presently involved in
right it is narrative in nature in part
but it's really about something well
beyond narrative it's about presumably
the same thing you know power unlimited
resources yeah
um
and it may be about a fundamental you
know it may be about uh
great resets or other euphemisms for a
massive one-time shift in uh how the
world runs and who benefits from it
next question
second question from the Discord
what standard do you use to classify a
species as invasive
the goal is to maintain the status quo
of an ecosystem in all places on Earth
isn't that the death of evolution
so to the second part of this question
is a non-sequitur because uh the
identifying a species is invasive is not
the same as saying we need to keep
things exactly as they are those are not
those are not the same thing at all
um they're the boundaries between them
might be closer than you would think for
some people's definitions or very much
farther
um
but specifically I guess I would say one
of one of the things is that an invasive
I don't think of a species as invasive
if it is contiguous with its originally
identified range if it is simply
expanding its range you know climate
change anthropogenic or otherwise is
allowing a lot of species to change
first phonologies and then their actual
ranges that is to say first you know for
not like you know when it is that they
set you know when is they set flowers at
seed rather
um and you know once that starts to
happen starts to change then they can
expand their range either North or South
depending uh and that's not
an invasive species that's in the range
expansion which has effects of course
and uh you know I think species will go
extinct as some species expand their
ranges because they're just you know
becoming better competitors at what used
to be the edges of their ranges but an
invasive species is
in general
I might I shouldn't say in general I
think
when I think of an invasive species it's
one that has been moved
into a new place that is not contiguous
with where it was originally so I would
say that the key there are two key
characteristics one is competitively
Superior
and two is moved by humans
so that is to say so introduced species
um will be moved by humans but it may or
may not be competitively Superior in
which case it may just equilibrate or it
may go extinct right you can have
whereas if it is moved by humans and or
by on the on the muddy feet of a duck
right yeah
um and it is comparatively Superior uh
it can become invasive and not merely
introduced
yes in fact it almost certainly pending
some it's a great risk when its
population is near zero and the new
habitat of going extinct which is
hopefully what it does
um but uh given a little bit of luck at
the beginning
because it is competitively Superior uh
it will start driving out native species
virtually anywhere and it is one of the
truly terrible environmental
catastrophes
of modern times is that human beings
solve a dispersal problem for creatures
that then have competitive superiority
for reasons that uh I I think I have
some insight into we do not yet well
understand what we collectively do not
well understand what creates competitive
superiority that allows for Invasion but
um effectively
you can transport things you can even
transport things that grow where they're
going that are still in no danger of
becoming invasive right you can
transport an ornamental and grow it in
your garden it is the competitive
superiority that makes them devastating
because it means that you lose control
of them and they take off and it's very
very difficult if not impossible in most
cases to put the toothpaste back in the
tube right you just you'd have to find
you know everything
foreign
yeah that's a very
hilariously
you'll begotten metaphor but
um but yeah the you know the uh hydrilla
that came out of the bilgewater of uh
ships in the Panama Canal I mean I guess
yeah I think zebra mussels probably got
into the Great Lakes
well I guess maybe they were attached to
the halls of ships rather than
bilgewater yeah
um uh eucalyptus that is taking over
California and the Andes yeah it's a
disaster and it's really it's
because people are not good at spotting
which the native species are in which
the invasives are
um
people do not realize how devastating
this is right yeah and how diversity
reducing it is yeah you don't you
you kind of need to have an
to have real familiarity with an
ecosystem and or have an eye like have a
an artist's eye
so in Portland where the English ivy is
out of control
it just you know hillsides look green
and that can look really beautiful until
you have a botanist's eye and you see
that what should be a mixture of Sword
Ferns and Vine Maples and Huckleberry is
both deciduous and Evergreen and salal
and Oregon grape and on and on and on is
instead just ivy
so you've got a monocrot because you
kind of introduced something that was
introduced and is competitively Superior
and therefore is invasive and
um
I think
you know Scotch broom is the same way
yeah it's like oh that's beautiful it's
yellow it blooms yellow it's like it's
pretty but it takes over everything and
then nothing else can can be there none
of the Native species can be there which
then of course has effects on Native
pollinators native seed dispersers
native fergivores which then of course
has effects on Native carnivorous that
would be eating the native uh
pollinators and sea dispersions and
frugivores and so you know you read
trophic levels is an imprecise model
um but it's but it's a it's an accurate
concept with imprecise imprecision in it
and if especially if you're invasive
species is at the plant level and it
starts wiping out other native plant
species you just got a cascading problem
that is going to be very hard to I don't
know toothpaste back in the bottle or
Genie back in the Tomb you put the genie
back in the tube yeah that's better than
the muscle zebra thing
[Laughter]
um yeah and you know
it ain't just the plants right no it's
not we have the wrong squirrels right
the native squirrels are being driven
out by you guys you need to be an expert
to Spot the Difference dumbest
amphibians the world taking over every
place cane toads have been introduced
they are so dumb
yeah
I thought you were talking about the
Biden Administration which you're
talking about cane toads they're not
toads uh I thought you were
describing them as done amphibians but
yes the brilliant flatworm it's a low
bar but they're flat so yeah they can
get under a low bar
platform limbo
oh man that sounds like a very difficult
game to judge
indeed usually limbo is self-judged
isn't it uh it's sort of self-judging in
the sense that when the bar comes
crashing down you didn't do it
yeah yeah well there's that too I guess
yeah
all right sorry I should not be clapping
with the lapel mic oh my god
um let's go to the first question here
on darkhorsesmissions.com
Heather can't thank you enough for
helping me keep my sanity for the last
few years love you and all you are doing
question I'm in Portland for one day
until tomorrow night what should I do
and where should I eat opened anything
yeah well we mentioned a lot of our
favorite places but hardly all of them
last week so go take a look at the show
notes last week I listed just a bunch of
restaurants we gotta give her I would
say but we also you know we didn't
mention pambiche no we didn't BJ is a
Cuban restaurant that's terrific all
right here here's the thing yeah if
you've got one dinner to have in
Portland
foreign
it is
definitely what Portland should be
um you'll get to try a bunch of
different things almost everything is
great
um save room for dessert and have the uh
I don't know I can't say it and I guess
I'll say it it's called a whipplicious
which I never would have
yeah I guess we did
um but anyway I'd say that that'd be the
place to eat what's the one thing to do
well I mean if you have if you have
access actually
I would go paddle boarding on the
Willamette now that became a thing that
I did while we lived in Portland I'd
never done it before I guess we paddle
boarded on lake bakalar in uh Mexico
near the Belizean border with our boys
when we were there over Christmas 2016.
um but I became a paddle boarder on the
Willamette in Portland summer 2020.
and there are places that you can rent
them I think
I think George Rogers and um and Park
and Cedar Oak boat ramp both south of
Portland the first in Lake Oswego the
second in Westland maybe you can rent uh
paddle boards and just go out
um for you know an hour or two hours
whatever and it's amazing
um Japanese garden
to large Parks I
the Pearl is wonderful the Pearl is
still wonderful even though
it'll give you a taste of some of what's
wrong with Portland and all the West
Coast cities and increasingly all the
cities yeah as well Powell's Pals is in
the pearl ish between the Pearl and
downtown Pals is an amazing bookstore if
you like that sort of thing which why
wouldn't you Pals is amazing yep all
right well that'll get you started yeah
I have heard a lot about excess deaths
right stevanovic the analysis uses a
five-year rolling average understanding
that this is meant to smooth out the
signal from the noise is five years
really the best time frame do we see
similar excesses when longer time frames
are utilized with 10 20 Etc years give
different results
this is an interesting question I
haven't thought enough about exactly
what is being done
this is this is a question that is new
to me I haven't given this any thought
before
um
I guess I'd like to see it I'd like
I was gonna say I'd like to see it done
but I'd like to know first what I think
and I'm not sure yet what I think
um I think for this set of questions you
are inherently looking for a short time
scale and that
the question of time scale is always
going to be
[Music]
um
it is always going to be heavily
affected by what process you are
interested in
discovering its presence or absence so I
do think short time skills you have to
do it on that because let's say that
we're looking for I mean what we're
really looking for is
excess deaths as a result of covid alone
and then using that to find excess
deaths that are the result of coven Plus
uh the so-called vaccines
and you have
let's put it this way if you're looking
for the signal of the vaccines
foreign
has a built-in conservatism which is
good the chances that you will see a
phantom that isn't there are reduced
because
um the because to the extent that
certain people were very vulnerable to
covid many of them were lost or became
immune because they got it and survived
it or became somewhat immune
and so to the extent you see excess
deaths in 2021 that you didn't see in
2020 it implies something about our
remedies yeah but I mean this five-year
rolling average thing I'm just not sure
exactly what is being done so I mean I
feel like this is a statistical question
and neither you nor I I think from what
you just said know exactly what is being
done the five-year rolling average
suggest that something is being done
mathematically that I'm not totally
clear on and one of the things that is
true is that we effectively have three
moments in time
uh that we are interested in comparing
to one another and one of them you know
is 2019 and earlier and one of them is
just 2020 and really you know just three
quarters of 2020 really which is Coveted
but no vaccines and one is 2021 going
forward and because that middle period
which is
um yes coveted no vaccines no covet
vaccines is so short I think therefore
you want
um if it's a rolling average you want
that that that unit to be as short as
possible as well but
I I have to know exactly what is being
done
yeah I mean I would
one of my favorite people on topics of
uh covet hazard
is John Campbell and the reason that I
say that he's one of my favorites is
that he has been
in my opinion if you're trying to figure
out what's going on
more careful than necessary he is aired
in the direction of being careful while
not being the least bit cowardly with
respect to talking about what he was
seeing yep um the one place uh that he
is
uh
he did check out his last video on
excess deaths or recent video on excess
deaths he goes through the logic of it
very carefully he does
establish that there's a very clear
signal he talks about all of the
possibilities that he can come up with
for explanations save one which he says
look I'm forbidden to talk about this
one because of YouTube Community
guidelines which leaves you to connect
the dots
um you know and I wish he hadn't had to
do that but I understand why he did but
anyway he's been so careful about these
analyzes that I think you'll be struck
um by what he does now the work wasn't
his he's reviewing work that was done by
somebody else
so it's conceivable that he would have
chosen a different uh time period but I
think the answer is these things aren't
heavily sensitive
to you know the difference between a
five-year or a six year right it might
be a difference between you know a five
year and a ten year shows a substantial
uh change in the direction of noise
because it includes a period that is
less comparable right the number of
things that is different over a ten
years yeah
um so anyway I think the point is the
pattern is so clear that one doesn't
need to worry terribly much about
whether that's exactly the right period
over which to study it
right but you I mean if if a 10 or 20
year Rolling average would uh reveal
less pattern and you you know you really
think that the pattern is so clear you
should put it to that analysis and then
be able to say see I went conservative
here like I you know this this would be
less likely to reveal pattern and it
still does
well but I don't think that's how it
works because
the problem of what factor is captured
in a 20-year rolling average that would
be absent from a five means that it's
not inherently conservative it's noisy
and high variance
um so you might augment a pattern beyond
what it actually is you might erase a
pattern that actually is and the the
thing that we can say is that the period
of time that is most similar to the one
we live in is the one directly prior to
it yep
okay next question is a merchandise idea
merchandise image idea Heather sign off
we go to the ones you love eat good food
get outside wrapped by a stylized but
unmistakable scarf
I like it
um
Brett in your first Jordan Peterson
podcast in your point about the online
landscape being post-modern you said
quote people who think the internet has
Primacy are now exerting a force to
correct the real world in the direction
of their naive internet understanding of
things
would you define them as transhumanists
love to you too
yeah I think I would I think that's a
very good point they're behaving as
transhumanists and the the problem is
that um
nature bats last that the
meat space has Primacy whether you think
it does or not and yeah it is their
naive
transhumanist instinct to take the
online rules and write them over the
reality rules
uh yeah
the basic answer is yes well done I
think I think you've nailed it yep
in case we're still looking for a fresh
term for excessively woke people I
propose Academia nuts yeah I like that
one yep I have unfortunately made that
pun too but
vaccines and homeopath vaccines and
Homeopathy both seek to train the body's
response with moderate amounts of
harmful substances
why does one work but not the other
start that again vaccines and Homeopathy
yeah both seek to train the body's
response with moderate amounts of
harmful substances why does one work but
not the other
uh wow there's a couple things going on
here yeah one I have two as well
um
training the immune system with tiny
amounts of exposure to things relevant
to an actual pathogen is a method with
an actual mechanism
because it because it uses what the
immune system does let's put it this way
you can't just take any old thing you
have to take something that is
molecularly consistent enough that
inducing a reaction to it at the immune
level provides a specific reaction when
that formula shows up again in the form
of a live pathogen
Homeopathy the problem with it
is that it
takes the idea of a sub it takes an
actual substance and then dilutes it
away to the point that it's effectively
not there and so it basically so the
question uses the term moderate amount
so I would say Homeopathy specifically
does not use moderate amounts right it
uses effectively none the two distinct
differences therefore being that
vaccines are looking to use what your
effect what your immune system does in
order to teach it
uh whereas I don't I don't know enough
about Homeopathy to know if it ever is
trying to get your immune system to do
anything but I have the sense that it's
just like oh just let your body see it
it's like well that's not how poison
right you know poison response works and
um and then it's also not moderate
amounts right Homeopathy is just a tiny
now all right I there is a point about
Homeopathy that I have wanted to make
and I'm afraid to make it because I'm
afraid it will be misheard
but
um
the question is
actually you know what I'm gonna I'm
Gonna Save it and I'm gonna deliver it
in a context where I can flesh it out
correctly okay
um sorry about that I think it'll be
worth the wait no Homeopathy for you
guys
all right
next oh my computer is spinning hello
we just have to rip for a moment all
right so all the questions have
disappeared
all the questions have disappeared see
look do you think they were stolen
no I think it's coming back it's coming
back yeah
you should say something I totally
should say something
um sorry about this yes
um
we should introduce
now we shouldn't introduce I have it's
really not working
um yeah Zach if you have another oh oh
there we go
and
there we go
oh now with more questions oh makes me
wonder which ones might have been
missing before
yeah I know I had I had just then in
fact that's what it prompted it okay
no riffing necessary thank goodness
because I was failing at it oh but wait
now when I hit reload there's only hmm I
honestly don't know what's going on I'm
just gonna go with it what could we
learn from Russian literature which
works are your favorite
with some
with some prep time I could answer this
question well uh it's been a long time
since I've read much I was a huge fan of
Dostoevsky
back in high school
and remember particularly enjoying
Brothers K Brothers karamat stuff
but it's been a long time and I reread
it once in my 20s but it's it's been a
long time since I've gone back to it and
uh
and I've read some dull story in a dull
story told that I
don't know that is
um read some Tolstoy and
um some what church enough maybe
uh but mostly Dostoevsky and some told
story but you know what can we learn
from it they
guys are dark actually are there any are
there any
female russian novelists that that
people talk about I don't I don't know
if any of that coming up with any
um they just so the the dudes the
Russian novelist dudes are dark and deep
and see things about societal level
structures that are often missing
from
from the fiction of other other
nationalities
um you're not gonna add anything because
no I will I will say I am not a fan of
Russian literature I think you should
take your time with something as
important as literature
it's just worth it
that was a very disproving look well I
was trying to figure out if I should
call you out the fact that you've
probably never read a word of Russian
literature oh I've read how many people
decided to do so professionally I've
read
first line of Anna Karenina oh yes all
families yeah
exactly
uh yeah no I I have very little to add
yeah I'm not going to pretend to
be an expert yeah and I know who I
should read but I don't know much of
having read
I love the question I just
prepared for it
I am concerned about having a repeat of
covet authoritarianism in the name of
climate change it has forced me to take
another look at the expert opinions
expert opinions are you familiar with
the scientist Tony Heller he's on
Odyssey and runs realclimatescience.com
I'd be interested in an evolutionary
perspective on his work
I don't think I know Tony Heller I don't
recognize that particular name no
um but I would offer a caution
I think we can be certain covet has
revealed what broken science looks like
and there is essentially no chance that
climate science doesn't suffer from the
same kind of dysfunction climate science
is not going to be open to
countervailing evidence right which it
would have to be in order to understand
how strong the evidence actually is
that's right that said the discovery
that what we think is evidence all the
work that goes on that claims to
understand how intense the problem is
and where it's likely to go the fact
that that is all compromised by
scientism
does not suggest that we don't have a
problem and there are reasons to suggest
that we have a problem that do not
emerge from that modern uh
discipline
in fact the belief that climate change
is a hazard is very old and it arises
from extremely simple easy to
demonstrate feature of
chemistry atmospheric chemistry right
and
the point is yes CO2 traps Heat
it is embedded in a complex system so
it's hard to know what the net impact is
going to be we are altering the amount
of CO2 in the atmosphere nobody uh
doubts that and how could it be
otherwise the amount of internal
combustion that we are doing cannot help
but have that effect so the question is
is it negligible is it alarming and
further what is the interaction with
things like frozen methane in the Arctic
there's a huge amount of methane larger
large amounts tied up in these methane
clathrate
Composites and to the extent that we
melt novel amounts of that stuff we are
going to step into a realm across a
threshold where it's a positive feedback
that is completely out of our control
will we reach that threshold I don't
know but I can say it is foolish to risk
that our industrial processes
will push us across that threshold it is
even more foolish to risk
um the entire
catastrophe unfolding as a result of the
fact that we have allowed political
um Dogma to overwhelm scientific study
what we really need are excellent
scientists working on the question
completely free to discover whatever it
is that's out there so that they can
help us see and navigate at the moment
what we are doing is Flying Blind
because the very people who sit in the
seats of the scientists who need to be
warning us their discipline is
compromised by the belief that we
already know the answer and that
anything that points in the other
direction is going to embolden the
opposition so we can't afford to talk
about it
and coming to opposite conclusions gets
you blacklisted gets you you know you
you don't end up having a career uh
that's standard as a climate scientist
right now which which is
you know what it is the whole thing is
suspect unfortunately and it's it's just
dire
it's runaway climate science
I'm afraid and it's just that's the long
and short of it yeah runaway climate
science which obscures whatever is going
on with your private you're right
sometimes you're right sometimes I'm
right oh wow this is good you know that
I mean I did I didn't know you knew that
yes you did yeah
um
thoughts on excuse me thoughts on
DeSantis and Abbott sending illegal
migrants to places like Martha's
Vineyard kamala's House kamala's it's
been so long since I've said her name
Kamala I think it's Kamala Kamala I
forgot okay I'm gonna start over
thoughts on DeSantis and Abbott sending
illegal migrants to places like Martha's
Vineyard kamala's House in Chicago but
locals broke after only 500 imagine
dealing with thousands
um I didn't actually I'd only heard
about the Martha's Vineyard I didn't
know the camel's house in Chicago as
well when did this happen
um now what's happening now very very
recently okay yeah so yeah putting
putting migrants at the at the southern
border into buses I think and um
planes also and shipping them off to
Rich liberal enclaves and where there's
you know signs in front yards that say
we believe that document is illegal and
you know science is real and all this
and
um they it's it's nimbyism at its best
right and it's at its at its most
extreme where they're like we can't we
can't handle these people here
um it's a stunt for sure it's a it's a
political stud it's a PR stunt but it
does it does reveal a hypocrisy
100 well I don't know what to say about
this because my sense is it's so far
over the line that it's completely
unacceptable on the other hand the thing
it is responsive to is so far over the
line right that you know what landscape
are we even in and at at some level you
have to fall
those who uh
bent
federal policy to their political
objectives irrespective of the cost of
the nation I mean that's such a
Despicable thing to have done that I
don't know what tools just if
the point is okay the people who
altered the federal policy
so that it behaves this way also control
the media at such a level that the media
doesn't report on this extremely
newsworthy change in the way our borders
function you know that doesn't leave you
with the normal tools with which to
address this kind of dysfunction so I
don't know what the right tools are yep
um this one's under any normal
circumstances I would say this is
appalling it's a terrible thing to do
under the circumstances we're in you
know it's like it actually goes back to
the first question
we are in something like an undeclared
war and the point is how do you feel
about shooting people well in general
I'm against it in Wartime I want to know
who we're talking about and then I'll
tell you you know it's like that
um so yes the rules are very different
because somebody is making a war and
they just simply never mentioned it to
us right they're making war on the
structures that allow our society to
function yes indeed
okay
uh what do you think this from someone
who is called PDX pilot
what do you think of Instagram
nutritionists claiming there's no such
thing as good or bad food seems crazy to
me
well the first part of this question
that seems crazy is the idea that their
Instagram nutritionists yes frankly I
had no idea
um I don't know what that means but
there are Instagram nutritionists
um suggesting nutrition stuff on
Instagram I mean yes so my awesome 18
year old son who's also our producer has
explained to me what the words Instagram
a nutritionist mean
I think I think we've heard of this
there's something called a thirst trap
so presumably these people are selling
smoothies or something to those who are
very very thirsty is that right that's a
better answer do I have it I think you
have it yeah
um no I mean I don't know I don't know
if these are nutritionists in real life
who are then you know making a little
bit extra on Instagram or you know
feeding their interest in um being
influencers uh on Instagram or if they
are just playing nutritionists on
Instagram
real nutrition there's so much for hand
uh
this is their side Brussel
[Laughter]
well I guess yes
yes I also as I said that I thought you
know asterisk real nutritionists the few
times I have had occasion to be
to be on the receiving end of something
the nutritionist had to say about the
world I have I have yet to be impressed
and they have any idea what they're
doing I don't know what the training is
to be a nutritionist but I think
basically if it involves getting
anywhere near the food pyramid that the
FDA put out you know years ago then uh
that's
obviously they have their Bonkers they
just have no idea what they're doing so
unless they have any ability to think
evolutionarily why would you trust them
at all the idea there's no such thing as
good or bad food
um this is like people claiming that
there's no unhealthy body weight
it's just wrong obviously it's just
wrong there are there are a range of
foods that have been thought were bad
for you that turn out not to be bad for
you or might be bad for you under some
circumstances or when you know when you
are old but not young female but not
male pregnant or not
um you know there are a number of
conditions under which yeah that
actually you shouldn't be eating that
now or as much as you could then or if
you were EX
but is there bad food yeah
fast food burgers are bad food well fast
food burgers are potentially bad food
but
it's a lot simpler than that I mean
sugar for example refined sugar we do
not have a system that is built to
modulate it and the problem is that's
because somebody cooked a burger fast
doesn't inherently make it bad what we
call fast food burgers are not produced
that way and so they are but
um you you know you know better than
that it's not a fast food Burger isn't
oh I took a choice piece of grass-fed
and finished beef and used all the best
produce and I just cooked it really fast
that's not what a faster I know but the
problem is it the problem is in defining
what it is that you're saying is
actually bad and is hard to explain I
don't know what goes into a fast food
Burger it's the commodity beef and the
seed oils that it's cooked in and the
GMO produce that is put on it and the
commodity grains that are probably grown
with glyphosate they're used to make the
buns and again the seed oils on The
Griddle that they're grilled on you know
that's part of of it yeah so in some
sense oh and the preservatives and the
buns and probably and oh and the colors
in the meat to make it look fresher than
it is because it's aging so it probably
has bacteria in it and the artificial
flavors and the fact that the beef may
come from many different animals at once
so if some animal is sick you're much
more likely to uh to get it yeah all
those things
um
things are bad but I would just say that
the
the reason to prefer something like
sugar is that by narrowing it to one
ingredient that we know is very bad for
us because it messes up a system that is
supposed to modulate the degree of this
stuff and we overwhelm that system very
easily
you know it becomes an unambiguous
question right
so yes in answer to your question
um nutrition is way worse than
electrician because electrician stood
the test of time did you have like a pun
drought for a while or something it's
it's constant today
it's constant no it's ratcheting up it's
a result of hunger we haven't eaten
anything today and and it is causing
we usually haven't eaten before the live
stream because we usually engage in this
like intermittent fasting thing we do it
like that's not new this week that is
constant
I think there have just been four
opportunities that showed up in quick
succession three of them pretty good and
I couldn't help myself one of them
terrible
no one of them was terrible which one it
was the nutritional one I I I regret
that one okay okay so do I yeah okay
another one that you said was pretty bad
earlier on in the live stream I'm
distinctly if so I blocked it out okay
yeah in order to live with yourself yes
exactly okay but how do we live with you
then that is a question I've wondered
about
okay
um oh that's I think I already hit yes I
already had answered on that but I
the breaking points team talked about
this week here's a link on Instagram
very much appreciate you too I think
this is going to be a link to the
nutritionist one or is that a different
question
uh it's so hard for me to copy and paste
here hold on let me uh just a minute
sort of ramble on for a bit and see if I
can get this uh
oh yeah good for oh it is oh those
people do kind of look like they're
maybe trying to be thirst that way those
are these are good versus bad foods in
collaboration with foreign
Savage X fatty and black dot
nutritionist
moralizing food as good or bad can lead
to unhealthy relationships with food and
disordered eating oh for [ __ ] sake
okay you know it's a bad food God's sake
what's a bad food cyanide that's a bad
food
yeah it's a bad food
totally yeah
arsenic apple seeds yeah but those
aren't Foods you have to find your apple
seeds are bad food well my point is or a
bad food
I have not personally
good but I will ever quite good oh
okay smells delicious
does smell pretty good what is happening
in my experience
remember she had dark writes most
so-called laws both here and abroad
violate either property rights or
freedom of Association and should be
rejected
I'm gonna have to think about that
um there actually I hate to do it here
buried in the Q a I meant to do it
during the main podcast but I'll do it
anyway a couple things I forgot to say
with respect to
uh Portland that I wanted to say one of
them was this we could also do it next
week
okay maybe we'll come back to it but I
do want to say there is one law
that is different when you cross the
border from Oregon to Washington
uh where I feel like we just took a
massive step backwards by moving back to
Washington yeah up here it's not such an
issue in fact it's not much of an issue
at all but in the San Juan Islands but
the comparison between Seattle and
Portland and this would be
they're just huge
Oregon
has very tight regulations about the
emissions from your vehicle it's
California like in this regard and it
forces you to get your vehicle emissions
tested in order to register it and you
know what it's a huge pain in the butt
that's totally worth it right it's
totally worth it and you remember that
every time you're behind some vehicle
the belt is a huge amount of exhaust
that then comes into your car and you
end up breathing it that stuff is
damaging to your brain it's damaging to
your physiology it is shortening of life
it is a disaster and it is a marvelous
example of an externality
because the point is your exhaust is
behind you right you are not paying the
cost of your own exhaust belching from
your vehicle so the incentive to fix it
is very low absent the state's
intervention now does the state end up
taking your money yes does it do so
largely
getting vehicles that don't have a
problem tested yes is it worth that cost
in order not to be Downstream of other
people's badly tuned cars and the
exhaust that they're putting out
absolutely it changes not only is the
aesthetic quality of life but it changes
Health in a meaningful way and and
children's development considerably you
know less so now that the lead isn't in
the gasoline but still but still yeah
and
so anyway what I would say is look there
is a tension the bias that the founders
put into our founding documents the um
the belief that the government that
governs best governs least which does
not mean doesn't govern right it means
governance as little as possible in
order to accomplish the objective right
those are good biases but they are
biases they are not absolute rules and
so yes
governance interferes with freedom right
it has to otherwise it isn't governance
it should interfere as little as
possible and as elegantly as possible
but it can't be zero and
um
you know the same thing can be said of
Taxation right taxation can be appalling
as as it is in western states that don't
govern and heavily tax and drive away
the tax base with which they might
actually help the people that they claim
to be helping right it's it's a you know
it does become theft at that point but
it's not inherently theft right taxation
is inherently necessary in order to
deliver services and you know there are
a lot of different ways you could do it
but I think we need to be
adult about these questions right how
much Freedom should you have as much as
possible but not it should not be
maximized how much taxes should you pay
as little as possible given the services
that make civilization better right and
you know there's just no perfect way to
do it
um what we should aspire to
is a system that delivers Lots as
cheaply as possible and as effectively
and and uh
um
as
what's the term I'm looking for as
elegantly as possible but
those are objectives they're they're not
going to be perfectly achieved
indeed here's a comment
the World War One World War II World War
III nomenclature works fine as long as
you assume that one was the Napoleonic
Wars two was 1914 through 1947 and three
is next thus alienating you from a
virtually everyone else I like it I like
it too
yeah
I'm I've
been delving a little bit into this uh
what actually was the distinction
between World War one and World War II
uh question and you know you read you
read people's Live accounts in you know
in Europe uh in
1922 1932
um you know even especially if they're
not in in Germany and they they think
it's over but what is it at what
actually is going on uh it's
it was it was pretty consistently awful
there for many decades
I think we have time for two more only
we've got a few more questions than that
but um
any thoughts on Queen Elizabeth II's
passing
what does she represent to you
thank you and much love
um I think that this is actually a
pretty
deep and not a simple matter
in principle I am about as far from a
monarchist as you could get
but in practice I do Wonder
if
the fact of the monarchy
has an importance that is lost because
of the anachronism of the monarchy and
what I said to the patreon Coalition of
the reasonable group this morning
was that
boy
this is tough but it requires a weird
analogy
post-menopausal women
do not because they do not have the
ability to produce more offspring of
their own their Viewpoint should
naturally tend towards the big picture
and providing an environment in which
the children and grandchildren that
exist or will exist are embedded in a
functional system right so you expect a
kind of wisdom to evolutionarily emerge
if you compare that to let's say
uh wealthy men who not only are
physiologically capable of continuing to
produce Offspring but may even have the
opportunity to do it by virtue of their
wealth okay you would expect them to be
the same age control there right you
would expect them to be uh narrowly
focused jerks right and you would expect
uh postmenopausal women to be a big
picture trade-off balancing uh lineage
oriented in their thinking right Polar
Opposites effectively
and
here's the odd fact monarchy is
inherently
a kind of corrupt
um structure because the power that it
has
tends to result in the abuse of that
power right there's there's no Magic by
which good people end up as monarchs and
so you're going to get a lot of humans
taking advantage of you know in modern
times their tax exempt status but taking
advantage of the power that a monarch
has and that's terrible on the other
hand
a monarch is only a monarch if their
society continues to exist
and so you might imagine that as much as
there are good monarchs and bad monarchs
that in general the monarchy has a bias
towards preventing a civilization from
disappearing right because it loses
everything if the civilization it's
embedded and disappears and so it may be
that monarchs are very rarely useful but
that because they are dependent on the
society they are embedded in continuing
to exist they will tend to see hazards
that others don't I don't know that this
is true I don't know that it's been
demonstrated to be true but I leave
openly it exists along with like a
parliamentary government or some such as
opposed to just just having a monarch
well this would be a feature of all
monarchies but in modern times I think
that here's the problem people in
general liked this queen right they
don't in general like monarchy but they
like this I don't even know that in
general is the right word I feel like
she was beloved in a way that
with the universality that I can't I
don't I I mean I think this has been
said widely you know so many people have
spilled so much ink on on her passing
but
she was more beloved universally beloved
than anyone else I can think of yes and
I think you know well look I know very
little about the queen but what I do
think I know is that a there's some
interesting early story something
Jeeps wartime that she did you know as
Royals sometimes do she
observed effect she was a real human
being with real skulls who was actually
willing to get her get her hands dirty
and she was
uh at least as far as I know not an
obvious abuser of
power right she certainly benefited from
a huge amount of privilege but she was
not you know even in her interface with
governance was careful
so
we're going from a monarch that people
generally liked
to a monarch that people don't generally
like right and the point is the tendency
to say oh well now's the time to get rid
of the monarchy because we don't really
like Charles who needs a king right a I
agree that that's probably true B what
do you give up that you don't realize is
valuable because the periodicity of its
value is so
long
um and you know I you know do I want a
king no do I think bridge should want a
king my instinct is no but I'm far from
saying it's obvious that this has no
purpose and you know be done with it I
don't know is the answer one should be
cautious yeah I mean I guess there's
also
I think you know neither of us had
particular you know personal connection
here I had I had one moment of Royal
Focus as a as a young person uh when
actually when Charles and Diana got
married you know I on the west coast of
the US I got up early and I watched the
wedding even though I was not I did not
have princess fantasies that was not the
kind of kid I was at all but uh
something about that story uh really
drew me
uh and uh you know of course it was
revealed very quickly to be nothing like
the fantasy that we were told told it
was
uh but in none of that did Elizabeth
ever
no one ever blamed her for any of her
decisions even when she made unpopular
ones or even and I can't think of any at
the moment but I'm sure she made wrong
ones but she was always honest and
forthright and careful and and owned her
mistakes I believe
um
but I think one of the things that is so
unusual so I guess and you know we
didn't prep for this at all but I guess
she was the longest reigning British
monarch even longer than Victoria who
similarly had you know I don't know that
she was as beloved but Victoria's death
uh through all of the Talk's gonna push
my computer over here
um all of
all of British Society was just in in
uproar when
when Victoria died and
time moved more slowly than it wasn't a
global economy and so part of what that
was was as now was this is all we've
ever known
for the vast majority of humanity than
with Victoria but especially now with
Elizabeth to the extent that you were
aware even if you're not a bread even if
you didn't care about the Royals
whatever you know well Queen Elizabeth
II was always just a fact of life
and so there's a way that the normal
process of grief is but wait I thought
I thought that person I loved I thought
that animal that I loved was permanent
everything about my experience told me
that was permanent even though yes I
know death is real yes it happens
but especially because this was someone
who almost none of us actually knew
she was just in the background a fact of
life and obviously she was so old it was
going to happen at any moment
but it's still shocking to have that
thing that yes you know intellectually
is going to disappear but it's always
been there so maybe it won't maybe this
will be the exception you know we our
brains play these strange tricks on us
so I think a lot of people are also
actually grappling with
the reality of reality and you know not
in a bad way not in like a postmodern
silly like oh I just didn't realize way
but just in the way that oh you know
even
even people who lose a loved one after a
protracted battle with a disease they
know it's coming and they know it's a
relief to the person who was dying and
to some degree to their loved ones it's
still a shock wait a minute but they've
always been there
the hole that it leaves is huge and so I
think the fact that she was apparently
by all accounts an incredibly good human
being and that she no longer is
and she was for so long
that that combination is rendering many
people incapable of knowing exactly how
to proceed
well there's one note of caution I want
to add to this so I've talked to a
number of people
in the aftermath of her death including
a couple of Brits and uh a Canadian
For Whom the queen is still a relevant
person in a way that I don't entirely
understand but
um but it was a commonwealth Nation yep
Queen is a significant factor but in any
case the point is
one person in particular alerted me that
they are feeling
oppressed by the enforced period of
mourning and that it is not just simply
a the flag is at half-mast for somebody
you have misgivings about or something
that it is actually an active process in
which you are told that you were going
to engage in you know 30 seconds of
Silence
for the queen and if you opt out by
leaving you will be understood to be you
know somehow other
and this always troubles me right to the
extent that look it's 2022.
there is an obvious question about
whether a monarch has a place in a
western
Democratic Republic right that's simply
a real question that cannot help but be
one
and the idea that one is to it is not
the fact of
uh Elizabeth
that is causing the state to effectively
mandate mourning it is the fact of a
monarch having died
and so I guess the note of caution would
be
for those of us who are concerned about
abuses of power about the west and the
thing that makes it unique but also
makes it fragile
the idea that there will be
effectively an authoritarian
uh insistence on a perspective on
monarchy
for citizens of a western Democratic
Republic I do find that disturbing it's
one thing if Britain or Canada or
Australia or New Zealand find themselves
organically in mourning and leave room
that some of their members may not feel
that way right but you know when John F
Kennedy was shot
nobody told the public you will now feel
bad the public felt bad right yeah
um
was there room for somebody not to feel
bad
formally yes
how would it have been socially to not
feel bad I don't know but
um but I think the point is there is a
difference between
Britain organically finds itself
mourning this person who is suddenly
gone
and the state is now going to force you
to mourn I think those two things look a
lot alike but they're really very very
different
okay we're up against our time limit but
I promised one more question so this one
we could go on for hours but let's try
to do no puns
please
Republicans when in November will there
be a return of antifa and BLM
that's an interesting question
I think first of all as I see it in Tifa
and BLM are real phenomena that have
become tools of something very different
from them right but these things are for
public consumption and that there is a
kind of power that we do not understand
that is utilizing
those instincts and people sympathetic
with those movements they're a means to
an end yep and so if
there is a red wave in November my sense
is that that means that those things
didn't work and so what I would expect
is to see
the next phase in the evolution of this
arms race rather than a return
to those phenomena that doesn't mean
those phenomena won't attempt to return
but I think the point is I will yeah
let's figure something else out is what
will happen over on the blue side
yeah maybe we should stop there maybe
you should end it there rather than
uh yes I think I think that's good I
mean I don't think it's good at all but
I think that's I think that's good for
now
okay we'll be back next week probably
right here uh
concluding it for you with dark horse
podcast The evolutionary lens uh there
will be an episode of uh a guest episode
of Dark Horse with Brett interviewing
someone out before we see you again look
out for that one and
um until then be good to the ones you
love eat good food and get outside
hold up just go on somehow